in shakespeare for weeks a site of
tension and protest
a new level of violence
six members of the israeli security
forces injured the driver shot dead in
his seat seconds later
witnesses told us the man a palestinian
from occupied east jerusalem
shouted allahu akbar as he approached on
edge
israeli forces driving our team and
others from the immediate area
four palestinian families further down
this street are facing
imminent forced expulsion from their
homes their fate driving many of the
protests that proceeded
that has sent into the air strikes
rocket fire and communal violence
of the last week shaitara was the focus
of so much of the simmering tension that
we saw here
throughout the month of ramadan tension
that sparked violence that has spread
far beyond here violence that is
continuing a short drive from
shakespeare an israeli settler with film
taking aim at palestinians
two were later reported shot and injured
these were the arrests that followed in
a settler home
israel's prime minister calling the
explosion of racial violence
the second front in this crisis the
other front has so far not relented
more heavy rocket barrages out of gaza
in ashkelon a synagogue was struck
israeli attacks on gaza also unrelenting
the toll
in people killed and displaced in homes
destroyed
still mounting israel's security cabinet
reportedly not discussing a rumored move
towards ceasefire negotiations the prime
minister
taking his argument onto u.s television
we're trying to degrade hamas terrorist
abilities
and to degrade their will to do this
again so it'll take some time i hope
it won't take long but it's not
immediate but there's also a report that
egypt
offered a truce hamas said yes you said
no why
well that's not what i know and frankly
if hamas thought that they could just
fire on our rockets and then sit back
and enjoy immunity that's false
by nightfall and shaykh gerard the
checkpoint had been reinforced with
heavy blocks
even if a ceasefire is coming between
israel and hamas
the violence here in the occupied west
bank and in israel
for now has a momentum of its own harry
fawcett al-jazeera
occupied east jerusalem